This Wendover Productions video was made possible
by Away.
Get $20 off the perfect suitcase from Away
with the code “Wendover” at checkout.
The Post Office Made America.
It’s an ambitious claim, I know, but without
it the United States as we know it today would
not exist.
As author Winifred Gallagher eloquently pointed
out in her book, “How the Post Office Created
America,” in the years following the American
Revolution, one didn’t say, “the United
States is,” they said, “the United States
are.”
The country at the time was just a lose collectivity
of states.
The national government was weak—people
identified with their state first and their
country second.
With the opening of the post office, however,
Americans across the continent had for the
first time a direct link to the federal government
and the outside world.
In the New England colonies that preceded
the United States, infrastructure was poor.
It was considered a great achievement when
travelers could finally reach New York from
Boston in under a week.
There was little emphasis on creating roads
between colonies since each was a unique,
independent entity.
Some have even attributed the colonist’s
lack of attachment to the crown to their lack
of roads.
Those living outside of cities might have
never met a royal official in their lives
just because of how hard it was to get around.
Given this, the crown’s postal service in
the colonies was slow, expensive, and emphasized
links across the Atlantic to Britain almost
more than it did links between the colonies.
Before the American Revolution there were
unofficial, almost black market ways of getting
mail around, but the increasingly legitimate
continental congress—the group that eventually
declared American independence—realized
that in order to properly coordinate and collaborate,
the member colonies needed a way to effectively
communicate.
Therefore, surprisingly, the United States
Post Office was founded almost a full year
before the United States itself.
In the century following its founding, the
US had a bit of a good problem—it expanded
in territory faster than it could expand in
people.
For much of its history and still to an extent
today, the United States was a country of
vast, untamed wilderness.
This was especially true in the early years
to the west of the Appalachians.
Despite the gold rush, California only hit
a population of 1 million in about 1890.
By that time the nation had a population of
over 60 million.
And between California and the Appalachians
during the early 1800s there was hardly anything—
especially roads.
California might as well have been an island.
To get there, most people and mail would take
a steamship down to Panama, cross the country
on land, and then reboard a ship to California
rather than attempting to cross the continent
by land.
People were naturally afraid to settle the
frontier.
The idea of being physically and informationally
detached from the civilized world while surrounded
by untamed and dangerous wilderness made it
difficult for the new nation to push west.
You have to remember that until the telegraph
became widespread in the 1850s and 60s, mail
was quite literally the only way to communicate
long-distance.
If you had a post office, you were connected,
if you didn’t, you were alone.
Therefore, one of the first steps for a new
town to legitimize itself was to appeal to
the federal government for a post office,
and this was usually granted.
Having a physical vestige of the federal government
in towns across the continent was immensely
beneficial.
Many would even say it played a large role
in America’s success.
You see the US today as a fiercely nationalistic
country, but, as mentioned, for a while state
came before country, however, these new brick
and mortar representations of the power and
benefit of the federal government helped tie
the nation together, but the post office’s
impact didn’t stop at its mere existence.
Newspapers shipped free—or at least close
to free—and that revolutionized the spread
of information.
In the 1850s, this meant that someone in brand
new Houston, Texas could read a newspaper
just as easily as someone in Washington, DC.
If it had been more difficult to distribute
national newspapers, individuals wouldn’t
have had information on national politics.
Without knowledge of national politics, the
state might have stayed as the dominant entity.
The long overland routes to tiny frontier
towns absolutely did not make money, but the
post office wasn’t supposed to make money
at the time.
It was there to make living in a frontier
town of 1,000 as similar as possible to living
in an east coast town of 100,000.
150 years ago, it took more than a month and
a half to travel to many parts of the frontier
from New York… if you could get to them
at all, however, the post office needed faster
routes so it created post roads—long rudimentary
overland routes.
With time and traffic, however, these post
roads developed into America’s first interstate
roads.
The informational links led to a physical
links.
A big question, however, was how to efficiently
get the mail out into and across the frontier.
In 1860, the railroad ended in western Missouri
and after that the mail had to go out over
land.
The Pony Express was a short lived commercial
express mail service connecting the end of
the railroad to California.
In only 10 days, it could get a letter from
the Atlantic to the Pacific.
This was unbelievable at the time.
Once mail arrived at the end of the railroad
line in St Joseph’s, Missouri, a rider would
take the pouch of a mail and immediately start
riding west at up to 25 miles per hour—full
speed—and then every 10 or so miles they’d
stop at a Pony express station to switch to
a fresh horse.
Every 75 miles, they’d switch riders to
keep the mail pouch thundering across the
country day and night.
This didn’t come cheap—it was the equivalent
of $130 to send just one half ounce letter—but
time is money and people did pay.
One of the most famous rides of the shortlived
Pony Express was following the 1860 presidential
election.
Telegraph did exist at the time but it didn’t
stretch all the way across the country.
The eastern line ended in Fort Kearny, Nebraska,
so immediately following the news of Lincoln’s
win, a rider set out west.
Using the relay system, riders made their
way across the country to Fort Churchill,
Nevada—the beginning of the western telegraph
line—to transmit the news.
The west coast papers therefore published
the news of Lincoln’s win only seven days
and 17 hours behind the east coast papers.
Just two years earlier, it took 17 days for
news to cross the continent.
This was an unbelievable feat.
With the completion of the transcontinental
telegraph line in 1861, however, the Pony
Express closed its doors after only 19 months
of operation, but it did play a big role in
the innovation of mail systems.
As mail volume rose to the west coast, the
US Post Office looked for ways to further
shorten the travel time across the continent.
Until the opening of the transcontinental
railroad in 1863, most transcontinental mail
went out to Missouri by rail before switching
to lower cost stagecoach rather than the Pony
Express.
At first all westward mail was put on the
train to be sorted in Missouri, but in 1862
the first post office on wheels was put into
operation.
A staffer would sort the mail while on the
move in an identical way as a post office
on land so when it arrived in St Joseph’s,
Missouri, it was all split up into different
bundles for different destinations.
This system proved incredibly successful and
in the coming decades, the post office gave
exorbitant subsidies and payments to railroads
across the country to move mail.
Most lines to small communities would never
have been financially viable without the post
office contracts they attracted.
The Post Office, therefore, was instrumental
in physically connecting small towns across
America to the outside world.
Expansion was getting easy.
This role in innovation happened once again
in in the 1920’s.
Aviation became big during World War One,
but once peace was settled it almost became
irrelevant.
Civil aviation was at first nearly nonexistent.
Just months after the end of World War One,
however, the first regularly scheduled airmail
route between DC and New York began.
By 1925, airmail routes stretched to hundreds
of towns all across the United States.
Just like with the railroad, the post’s
subsidies allowed for air service to towns
that would never have been profitable with
passenger only flights.
The US air mail service grew to become the
largest in the world making the US one of
the most connected countries in the world
and its legacy still survives today.
Many of the airlines that merged into United,
Delta, and American Airlines were founded
as airmail operators.
It’s easy to forget that 200 years ago only
8 million people lived in the 20 states and
four territories that formed the Union.
The continent filled in incredibly fast and
a lot of credit has to be given to the postal
system.
Few countries as large as the US have such
a strong national identity.
The spread of information is one of the greatest
determinants of a country’s success and
its unlikely the US would be such a global
superpower today without the education, connectivity,
and innovation that the post office bought.
Of the five largest countries in the world,
the US is the only to not have a serious present-day
sovereignty movement within its borders.
The has to be at least partially attributed
to how easy it has always been to spread information
across the country.
It may be obsolete today, but the post office
was once the peak of innovation—so much
so that it made America.
This video was made possible by Away.
This past weekend I travelled transatlantic
with my new Away suitcase and I can now honestly
say it's the perfect suitcase.
It’s just wonderfully designed.
It looks great and has a built-in TSA approved
lock on the top.
Inside, you put bulky stuff on the left held
in by the mesh and clothes on the right to
be compressed by the straps.
It has a spot for a laptop and even a waterproof
laundry bag to fill up as you go.
By far the best feature, though, has to be
the built-in battery to charge your phone,
tablet, or anything else powered by USB.
It can charge your iPhone up to five times
so that you know that you’ll always have
a charge when you’re on the go.
You can get your Away suitcase with $20 off
and free shipping within the contiguous United
States by going to awaytravel.com/Wendover
and using the code “Wendover” at checkout.
It's a great way to both support Wendover
Productions and get, as they say, “first
class luggage at a coach price.”
If you haven't already, please check out my
new podcast called Showmakers linked here,
check out my last video, and subscribe to
this channel.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you again
in two weeks for another Wendover Productions
video.